Are you here, Iman?
Yeah, I'm here. Okay, why do you keep
leaving and coming back?
It's cuz you said you'd take time,
that's why. No, stay here now. Now, you
know what the topic is. Is An-Nur one of
the names of your God, yes or no? Don't
lie like that other guy.
So, you say that again?
Is An-Nur one of the names of your God,
Allah?
An-Nur, you said.
You want me to spell it? I T
>> please. An-Nur, the light. Is the light
one of the names of your God?
>> [clears throat]
>> Um, I'll be honest, I don't know the
full 99 names. Okay, so if I show you,
will you agree?
If that's one of the 99 names, then
yeah, I'll agree. Okay, let me show it
to you.
Aisha Bewley's Islamic homepage, she's a
Muslima.
Right here on the screen.
The divine names, here you go.
You're going to read it for me, okay?
Right here, you see it on the screen?
Yeah. What does it say? Read it for me.
An-Nur, the light.
Read all of it.
The light, guide, the one who
illuminates, the one who is manifest,
clear.
And what ayah does it quote? First, it
says An-Nur is one of the 99 names,
right?
Yes. And then what ayah does it quote?
Quotes the Quran.
Uh, 2 2 40. 24 35, but read it. Not 2 2
40, you're reading the one above, the
one beneath.
>> 24 35. Mhm? Allah is the light of the
heavens and the earth. The metaphor of
his light is a a niche in which there is
a lamp, the lamp inside a glass, the
glass like a brilliant star, lit from a
blessed tree, an olive neither of the
east nor of the west, its oil
all but giving off light even if no fire
touches it, light upon light.
So now, it's one of the 99 names of
Allah, and Allah is the light of the
heaven and the earth.
Is your prophet the light of heaven and
earth?
Um, no.
Good. No prophet, if he fears Allah, has
taqwa, can be called the light of the
heaven and earth, right?
Yes. Good. Because I'm responding to
Sheikh Sheikh Inback who quoted John 9
to try to show that Jesus is just a
prophet, which means he doesn't know
what he's talking about. So now, if
Jesus is a good Muslim, can he say I am
the light of the world?
Um
No.
No, right? But he did. John 9:5, "While
I am in the world, I am the light of the
world."
That's in the Bible, though, isn't it?
So, how can he be Muslim?
But who quoted John 9? Your Sheikh
Inback Uthman. You want me to play the
clip again?
He quoted John 9 to prove his
>> Sheikh Uthman said this? Yes, he quoted
John 9 to show that the blind man said
he's a prophet. Do you want me to play
the clip again?
Sure.
Okay. Hold on a minute.
Hold on. One second, let me get the clip
for you.
Okay.
I already did
1 Timothy 2:5, so we're not going to
talk about that, but here, right here.
If he quotes John 9, this is why Sheikh
Uthman is a joke, but you guys think
he's great. But nonetheless, here,
listen.
Listen right here.
All right.
Here.
This is the Bible, right? Christian
Bible, right?
Here, for example, I'm going to show you
a few verses, all right? Cuz I don't I
want you to be knowledgeable, right? For
there's only one God and one mediator, a
messenger between God and men, the man
Jesus.
>> [clears throat]
>> Right? So, there's one God,
not two, not three, and that God sent a
mediator, a messenger, which is Jesus,
that is his messenger to mankind, right?
Now
>> the spirit is out of him. But I mean,
everybody has a soul, right? But God is
unique. Now, I'm going to show you this,
right?
This is the blind man who saw the
miracles of Jesus. Correct. They said to
the blind man, again, who do you say
about him because he opened your eyes?
Who did this miracle? He said he is a
prophet.
About Jesus, what did he call him?
A prophet, right?
This is the Bible.
>> But what did he quote? John 9. Yeah, I
see it.
>> man. So, why did he quote the blind man
saying Jesus is a prophet, but ignored
what came earlier when Jesus says, "I am
the light of the world"?
To be honest, I don't know what was
going through Sheikh Uthman's head at
that time.
>> He's a joke, brother. Don't He's not a
scholar, he's not an alim, he's a
jackass. Don't follow him. But if this
is true,
if you accept this as true, then Jesus
can't be a Muslim because he claimed
what only God can claim, if it's true,
right?
Yes. Okay, good. So, that's why I tell
Muslims stay away from the Bible. Don't
quote verses out of context cuz when I
show you the context, it's going to
prove Islam is false because in the same
chapter
a little later, watch here. John 9:35 to
38.
Jesus heard that they had put him out,
and after finding him, he said, "Do you
believe in the Son of Man?" He answered
and said, "Who is he, Lord, that I may
believe in him?" Jesus said to him, "You
have both seen him, and he is the one
who is talking with you." And he said,
"Lord, I believe." And he worshipped
him.
So, Christ said he's the Son of Man, and
the man called him Lord, a rab, and then
worshipped him.
Can you call Jesus rab? Can you say
Lord?
No.
Can you now worship Jesus and call him
Lord?
No. So, why did Uthman quote this
chapter?
Yeah, I I'm starting to see your point.
So, if you're going to tell me my
Bible's corrupt, leave it alone. Don't
quote it. Don't then quote a verse here
and say, "See, he's a prophet." But when
I read the context, he goes to show he's
more than a prophet, then you tell me
it's corrupt. So, then why did you quote
the chapter?
Yeah, but isn't there a contradiction in
the Bible, though?
Whether there's contradiction or not,
you are still left with the problem that
if you're going to quote any verse from
the Bible,
then you're being deceptive and
dishonest.
Meaning, if I tell you as a Muslim, your
Quran says
that Muhammad is mentioned in the Torah
and the Gospel that's with them.
So, they had a Torah and Gospel at the
time of Muhammad,
and that he's mentioned. So, if I ask
you, where is he mentioned in the Bible?
Where is he mentioned in the Gospel?
What would you point to?
Yeah, I don't know why Sheikh Uthman
said that. I see your point now. So,
don't quote the Bible. Tell me you think
it's corrupt, it's full of
contradiction, then we can have a
conversation about that, but he was
saying
that John 9 proves there is no Trinity
and Jesus isn't God.
That's what he said. And then he
misquoted 1 Timothy 2 to show Jesus just
a man, which I already dealt with, but
we can discuss. For example,
do you want me to show you in 1 Timothy
2?
You want me to show you which
Okay, here. This is what he quoted.
All right.
And I'm going to show you that if you
take verses out of context,
you're going to embarrass yourself. So,
he quoted, "For there's one God, one
mediator also between God and men, the
man Christ Jesus." So, Jesus is a man,
all right, good.
And there's one God. We don't believe in
three gods, but nonetheless, but does he
believe this part? The Wait, hold on.
Hold on. Hold on.
Why Why do you people say you believe in
like three gods?
I don't believe in three gods. Do you
believe in three gods?
Hell, no.
I don't believe in three gods. We don't
That's not what the Trinity is. The
Trinity is one God, this one God is
Father and Son and Spirit. But
the word Trinity is not mentioned in the
Bible.
And tawhid is not mentioned in the
Quran. Can you show me the word tawhid
in the Quran?
Tawhid wouldn't be mentioned in the
English Quran cuz it's an Arabic word.
>> There is no word tawhid in the Arabic
Quran. I'll take shahada if you show it
to me.
Do you believe in tawhid?
Yes, I believe in tawhid. I believe Show
me the word tawhid in the Arabic Quran.
I'll take shahada right now.
Um
Yeah, I'll check ChatGPT.
Let ChatGPT help you.
I want to go off camera. Off camera so I
don't see your face. Go off camera.
Yes, I Yeah, turn off the camera so I
don't see your face.
>> Yeah. Don't turn it on.
Okay, you said Trinity's not in the
Bible, but show me the word tawhid. Go
ChatGPT, is the word tawhid I'm saying
the word tawhid like you said the word
Trinity. Don't give me ahad, wahid.
I want the same word tawhid. Show it to
me in the Arabic Quran.
Yeah, just give me a minute, yeah? I'm
going to give you a minute. I'm going to
let you use AI.
Adam, you know what the topic is, I'll
bring you up afterwards.
Don't break your computer.
>> all your life?
I'm who?
Have you been Christian all your life?
I was born in a Christian home, but that
doesn't make me a Christian.
Mhm.
Right? I had lost my faith and didn't
believe in anything when I was a
teenager, but I came back later, and I
studied Islam. But focus Show me the
word
>> Okay. Okay. Um
in the Arabic Quran. Don't give me
wahid. I didn't say wahid, I didn't say
ahad. The word tawhid like you said the
word Trinity.
Um, it says to me no, the word word
tawhid tawhid itself does not appear in
the Quran. Thank you. So now, according
to you, because the word doesn't appear,
should I say then the Quran doesn't
teach tawhid cuz the word doesn't
appear?
I mean, IT DESCRIBES IT. OH, LIKEWISE,
the word Trinity doesn't have to be in
the Bible cuz the Bible describes what
the Trinity entails.
Mhm. So, don't ask me these kind of
arguments, man. These are bad arguments.
The word doesn't have to be in the Bible
for the Bible to teach what the word
implies. Try unity. One God, the Bible
teaches it.
The Father is said to be God, Son is
said to be God, Spirit is said to be
God, that's three,
but they're not three separate gods, and
they're not the same person. So, that's
why we came up with the word Trinity
like you came up with the word tawhid.
So, but
if you want to go back to 1 Timothy 2,
he just quoted saying, "See, there's one
God." All right, fine.
And Jesus is a man. Exactly, we still
believe he's a man in heaven. But, my
question to you, do you believe this
part?
He who gave himself as a ransom for all,
the witness for this proper time,
meaning Jesus gave his life
as a ransom to save people from sin. Do
you believe this?
I believe there is one God.
I know you do, and it's not the God
revealed in Jesus. We'll get there, but
do you believe this part? Cuz he quoted
only this part.
Do you believe this part?
That Jesus gave his life as a ransom,
that he died to ransom you?
Like
I'm not
Like, what do you mean by ransom me?
Ransom means he offered his life as a
sacrifice on the cross to save you.
That's what Paul means.
No, cuz I don't believe Good, you don't
believe it. So, why would you quote only
verse five and not six if you're a
Christian? Who quoted it? Who quoted it?
Uthman, we just read it. He quoted 1
Timothy 2:5.
I don't know why he quoted that.
>> Cuz he's stupid. But, now let's go to 1
Timothy 1. Let's see if Jesus is just a
man. Cuz he's not, that's what I'm
trying to say. You don't How does How
does this disprove Islam though, if he
quotes it?
Because you're trying to convince me, a
Christian,
to reject the Trinity, become Muslim.
But, if I read those verses, even if I
don't believe in Trinity, I can't
believe in Muhammad cuz he contradicts
these verses.
So, you're trying to convince me not to
be a Trinitarian, or you're convincing
me to become a Muslim?
At the end of the day, it's your choice.
All right, well, no, he's quoting the
Bible to show me to become Muslim.
That's why he's doing da'wah. But, the
Bible he's quoting shows I could never
be a Muslim if he's honest.
For example, [clears throat] in 1
Timothy 1, same book he quoted, right?
Paul, apostle of Christ Jesus, according
to the commandment of God our Savior,
Christ Jesus our hope. Now, when Paul is
writing this, Jesus is in heaven.
Do you believe that Jesus Christ issues
commands with God from heaven to us on
Earth?
Uh like, God gives Jesus commands. No,
Jesus is in heaven when Paul is writing
this. Not that he gives Jesus commands.
Do you believe in heaven, God and Jesus
together are giving commands to their
servants on Earth?
No.
But, Paul did.
He just said it, that's how he began it.
How about this?
To Timothy, my genuine child
>> [clears throat]
>> in the faith, grace, mercy, and peace
from God the Father, Christ Jesus our
Lord. Do you believe that Jesus is our
Lord in heaven with God the Father?
No.
So, why is Uthman quoting Paul in 1
Timothy when the first chapter buries
him and shows
this is not Islam?
But, I I have no idea what's going on
with Sheikh Uthman.
>> he doesn't know what's going on with
him. He's busy taking Muslim men's
wives. But, when you pray, you do
du'a, and you ask for salaam.
Salaam, when you say assalamualaikum,
that salaam comes from whom?
Where does that salaam come from? You,
or does it come from Allah?
Rahma. Salaam comes from
Okay, rahman salaam comes from who?
To be fair, I don't know what salaam
are. What to Allah I can say.
>> When you say assalamualaikum, you're
praying. Yes.
>> Peace be upon you. Who are you praying
to give them peace?
I am praying to God.
Can you pray to a creature in heaven to
give you salaam, peace?
No.
Can you pray to a creature in heaven to
give you mercy?
Rahma?
Pray to who, sorry? A creature to give
you mercy?
By creature, do you mean God?
God is a creature? Then that means he's
created.
Um
no, then.
Can you pray to a prophet or an angel
that's created to give you mercy? No.
So, now explain to me why Paul is saying
grace, mercy, and peace are from God the
Father and Christ Jesus our Lord. He's
saying, "The peace that I have, the
mercy that I received, the grace that's
shown to me, is from God the Father and
Christ Jesus our Lord, these two in
heaven." Does that sound like Islam?
No.